hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back to another ask me video uh
i figured i'd do more of these something
like once a month is the goal for 2017
because tech moves fast and also because
it's a new year's resolution so i asked
you guys on twitter of course and these
were your tweets and maybe i can get
questions from other places if you have
suggestions leave a comment below but
again it's twitter this time so why
exactly did you switch back to the mac
pro so uh if you've been following my
snapchat story or any of the things i've
tweeted about recently yeah i switched
back from editing full time these videos
on a macbook pro to the mac pro again
and honestly neither solution is
perfectly ideal for what i do right now
the mac pro is an old aging 2013
seriously four year old computer that is
still the highest end version that apple
makes and the macbook pro while still
has pretty decent new parts and
everything still doesn't quite keep up
with obviously super high resolution raw
red footage so any time i bring this up
obviously people are like oh well you
use final cut pro maybe just try adobe
premiere maybe build a pc for editing
videos well that's something i did
already a couple years ago and i
switched from that to final cut pro for
a bunch of other reasons including
performance so i know it sounds
hypocritical to stick with final cut pro
but i feel like a new mac pro this year
will solve hopefully a lot of my
problems what will you do if you win the
shorty award so if you haven't heard i
am nominated at this point for youtuber
of the year by the shorty awards which
honestly by itself is a pretty big honor
i'm on a list with people like nigahiga
philip defranco
lily singh people who are obviously huge
amazing youtube channels who make great
videos so that's cool enough for me i'll
link below if you want to vote for me
which that's very nice of you but if the
award ever shows up here obviously i
have a shelf now that i could put it on
which would be pretty cool link below if
you want to make that happen what's your
favorite wolf pick song okay you know
when you kind of find like a new artist
that you didn't know existed but happens
to be like the exact kind of music that
you like and then you just go down this
little rabbit hole of all the songs
they've ever made and find your
favorites that's what just happened to
me in like the last two weeks with
wolfpack so i will also link them below
and all the songs they've made i'm gonna
go with 1612 as my favorite but
obviously there's way more to pick from
your thoughts on the leaked images of
the galaxy s8 and the lg g6 honestly a
lot of the leaks for smartphones this
year have started to look pretty good
and i mean that's just not even counting
iphone 8 which is coming later or a note
8 which is coming later but if you've
seen galaxy s8 stuff if we ignore the
fact that the fingerprint reader looks
like it's in kind of a weird spot i'm
just excited for the fact that it looks
like a nearly actually bezel-less phone
the chin is tiny the forehead's tiny so
what if the speakers are bad like that's
a really cool looking phone and then lg
g6 also looks to be somewhat along those
lines we'll see that one probably before
the samsung so i'm pretty psyched i'm
pretty jazzed for what phones are gonna
look like this year if elon musk gave
you a free ticket to mars would you go
this is gonna sound
maybe a little weird but i think that's
entirely dependent on
the internet like does mars have its own
internet light takes like a little while
to get from earth to mars would we need
our own satellites and our own separate
internet our own separate youtube would
i not be able to watch any videos that
currently exist on youtube if i go to
mars and have mars internet or would we
all just deal with a tremendously huge
lag to game and watch videos and consume
internet from earth is that how it would
work i guess what i'm trying to say is i
probably wouldn't be one of the first
people to go but if i got a free ticket
i think i'd be down to being like the
second wave dead shoe battery was the
2016 sentence uh any 2017 sentence you
expect you would say soon
that's a confusingly worded question but
you know how in the video about the
hyper adapts i said dead shoe battery
situation that's a very 2016 sentence i
think a 2017 sentence would just kind of
be like oh this one still has a
headphone jack is the phone behind you
for sound proofing or for style okay so
this person's picked up on the fact that
there's actually phone behind me in
another one of my videos on the other
side of the studio that is
for both actually sam says who else
would you like to interview and what
youtubers do you want to collab with
that you haven't yet i think there's
tons of good answers for both and i'll
throw out elon musk as a name of a
person that i would love to interview
but obviously that's really hard to do
but uh for collaborating with other
youtubers i actually have a really good
idea for a video series that i'm going
to tweet about soon i think it's a great
idea but i'm going to tweet it just to
make sure it gets you guys approval on
it but i think it would be a great way
to collaborate with a bunch of other
people so look for that soon on twitter
it still ties in a little bit of tech
too it's perfect i think it's really
good here's a somewhat technical one do
you use color grading on your videos if
so can you teach us um the honest answer
is i do i try to avoid color grading i
mostly stick to what's called color
correction most of my videos about
gadgets and devices that are helping
people make purchase decisions are
people want to see this this device as
realistic as possible i want to make the
video look as real true to life as a
person looking at the device as possible
so i've mentioned this before there's
all kinds of great ways to color grade
and make videos look super cinematic or
you can change the mood or the look of a
video with both music and really
dramatic blue green magenta all kinds of
color grading but if i'm just trying to
find out if the iphone would kind of
look good in my pocket or if i kind of
like the way a certain software looks
none of that's actually going to help so
long story short with most reviews and
most device videos and stuff like that i
don't really grade it'll look as close
to real life as possible but i guess
with a little more creative videos or
maybe the dope tech series or stuff like
that where you're maybe not trying to
buy it at that moment but you just kind
of want to see cool looking stuff that i
will grade a little bit more so there
you have it thanks for asking your
questions for those of you who did today
on twitter and uh again stay tuned for
the twitter idea that i'm gonna just
plant and see if you guys have any ideas
because there's gonna be people i think
this this playlist will line up with i
don't wanna spoil it too much i'm just
gonna leave it at that thanks for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you